what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some really really
exciting news about Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania as if it wasn't already
exciting enough with the true
introduction of our new big bad Kang the
Conqueror yes we've seen him before as
he who remains but he who remains warned
us that his variants were a lot more
evil than he was
if you think I'm
evil well this way
till you meet bye variance
that's the Gambit so Quantum Mania is
going to be super exciting but to add
even more to it the director of the
movie Peyton Reed has confirmed that
there are going to be some major and
shocking cameos and I think everybody's
head automatically starts thinking
Fantastic Four however there are many
other cameos that could be popping up in
quantumania and I think we have a good
idea of just exactly how and why they
are going to be showing up in the movie
and cameos like Reed Richards and some
people from the Fantastic Four might
seem like kind of obvious ones due to
their Connection in the comics to the
microverse which is in the MCU the
quantum realm especially since Ant-Man
actually Saves The Fantastic Four in the
microverse in the comics but since
Peyton Reed said that there were going
to be some surprising faces we can
actually assume that we could be seeing
some other Avengers however I think it
might shock people to find out who these
new Avenger characters really are but
first let's go over the interview where
the stars talk about how there will be
cameos and this is Paul red talking and
the director Peyton Reed Paul Rudd has
said that we are going to see some
really good cameos in his interview with
Fandango this is what he had to say for
people that are aware I think we have
some good ones in there some really good
ones I'm obviously not going to tell you
what they are but I think that the ones
that people find out about or learn
about will it will be a 10. now this was
Paul Rudd's response to Fandango asking
him about secrets that Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania is going to have so
Paul Rudd himself says that there are
going to be some really good ones some
really good secrets that we'll find out
about in the film and he says for those
who notice these secrets meaning those
who can make the connections and know
what they are they're going to be a 10 a
10 out of 10 so these are going to be
some insane secrets that we're going to
see but it gets even better when
Fandango asked director Peyton Reed
about some cameos he directly answered
by saying oh yes there's great fun in
store for everyone and some surprising
faces that may show up in the quantum
realm so yes we're very excited this is
a pretty big tease he is straight up
telling us that there are going to be
cameos of characters inside of the
quantum realm and he specifically says
there are going to be some surprising
faces now I think that we're going to
see a combination of two things here one
is familiar faces and two is new
characters being introduced into the MCU
and let's just go ahead and talk about
the Fantastic Four first now the
Fantastic Four have been rumored and
theorized to be an Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania for years now what could be
the story of the Fantastic Four getting
stuck inside of the quantum realm just
seems to make sense plus you have to
take into consideration the fact that
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios came out in East said that the
Fantastic Four isn't really going to be
an origin story about The Fantastic Four
and now all of a sudden some things are
kind of connecting with each other rumor
has it and what I really believe could
happen and theorize about is that the
Fantastic Four are already stuck inside
of the quantum realm and this could
actually be how the Fantastic Four each
get their powers instead of the classic
origin story of them getting their
powers in space they could simply get
their powers inside of the quantum realm
because as we learned an Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania thanks to Janet Van
Dyne we know that she has powers because
the quantum realm changes you now we
originally thought that this could be
the origin of the mutants and the X-Men
and the MCU the quantum realm however we
have learned that that's not the case
but it is very clear that people can get
powers from the quantum realm so if the
Fantastic Four due to some sort of
experimental accident get stuck inside
of the quantum realm they could emerge
with powers just like Janet Van Dyne did
something like the quantum energy fusing
with their body could give them powers
and I think we could see the Fantastic
Four in a post credit scene for
quantumania we know that the Fantastic
Four are coming soon we know that
they're coming in 2025. now it was
originally supposed to come in November
of 2024 but according to some reports it
is now coming in February of 2025. so
it's still not that far away and if the
Fantastic Four really are stuck inside
of the quantum realm and this is sort of
an origin story for their powers it
makes sense that they would tease this
in a post-credits scene and here's how I
believe it would go down and has a good
chance of happening Kang the Conqueror
is going to be the next big bad so that
means he's most likely going to win an
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania from
what we kind of know so far thanks to
the trailers and some descriptions about
the movie can get stuck inside of the
quantum realm he then needs ant-man's
help to steal something most likely a
power source for his time chair to get
out so I'm assuming that King indeed
does get out but since he gets out and
he probably has the only power source in
time chair in there to actually get out
I'm assuming that Scott and hope and the
rest of the team actually get trapped
inside of the quantum realm I believe
that this is how the movie is going to
end but a post-credit scene Could Happen
setting up the meeting of the Fantastic
Four who could have been stuck inside of
there as well if Janet Van Dyne gets
stuck and they're with them she could
say that she might know of another
person who could help them get out she
could be speaking about Reed Richards or
if it's just simply Scott that gets
trapped inside and maybe Cassie and
maybe hope maybe Bill Murray's character
krylar could know of somebody else since
he really is kind of in charge of a huge
organization as well keep in mind that
Peyton Reed said that this movie really
is going to be a pivotal moment for the
MCU as a whole and it's going to be a
huge movie on the scale of an Avengers
film so a post-credit where Ant-Man
meets Reed Richards would make a lot of
sense and would be huge Reed Richards
would need the help of Ant-Man to get
out much like Kang did and of course at
this point Ant-Man would need help
getting out of the quantum realm as well
so you combine HIM Tech technology with
the smartest man alive Reed Richards and
I bet you you could figure out a way to
get out of the quantum realm now if this
happens that means that the start of a
Fantastic Four movie would be the
Fantastic Four stuck inside of the
quantum realm with Ant-Man which I think
would actually be really really cool
plus like I said in the comics Ant-Man
does help the Fantastic Four escape the
microverse which is the Quantum realm in
the MCU so there is a story for it plus
not to mention Kang whose real name is
Nathaniel Richards is a descendant from
Reed Richards they are actually related
so if we don't get the Fantastic Four
post credit scene there is a chance that
we could see Reed Richards or maybe a
variant of him and some other Fantastic
Four movies during the movie of
quantumania but that is just my theory
let me know what you think about that in
the comments down below now as far as
other cameos are concerned we know that
this is going to be a movie that is
about the Multiverse and variants Kang
will warn us that he has other variant
and he is trying to save us all from his
other variants but we also know that
King has an army and we know that he's
going to have some leaders of that Army
and like I said in some previous videos
I think some of the Avengers are
actually going to be high-ranking people
in Kang's Army there was a rumor going
around not too long ago that at some
point in time in The multiversal Saga we
could see some Avengers their variants
actually be bad and this makes sense in
the Multiverse in an infinite amount of
universes there is going to be universes
that exist where some of our good guys
are actually bad guys that's just how it
goes and perhaps some of them didn't
want to fight Kang but wanted to join
him this means that in Kang's massive
Army we could see some of the Avengers
who are bad leading that army fighting
alongside of King whoever the triumphant
King is whoever the King of Kings is in
this multiversal battle between all of
the different King variants it would
make sense that he would have a better
Army than the other variants and what
better way to have a better Army than to
get some superheroes on board except
they're kind of super villains I believe
that this is the other way that we could
see these cameos because Peyton Reed
said that we would see cameos inside of
the quantum realm now he already
revealed Bill Murray so we know that
that's not who he's talking about so I
think our best bet for cameos as in
who's going to show up is going to be
the Fantastic Four and some evil
variants of some Heroes that are very
well known now I'm not saying that
Robert Downey Jr or Scarlett Johansson
are going to pop up in this film
although technically yes it is possible
but I'm expecting characters like maybe
Thor maybe an evil version of the Hulk
maybe War Machine these type of
characters could pop up and could be
working with Kang either way I think
it's going to be really really crazy but
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comments down below and let
me know who you would like to see show
up as a cameo an Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news of course
you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter to stay up to date and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf